hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar hepatitis e virus the need for
improved testing i am marie stone of
labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by diasoren to learn more visit
diasoren.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
jacques isopet professor of virology
faculty of medicine toulouse propone
france and florence abravanel
mcu-ph faculty of medicine toulouse
prepan france jacques and florence you
may now begin your presentation
thank you first of all i want to thank
diazerin for organizing this seminar
uh florence and and myself are very
happy to share with you a recent advance
on hepatitis e uh
virus particularly in the field of
serologic diagnosis
with the new automated system launched
by diatherin
hepatitis e virus is a small naked virus
27 to 34 nanometer the capsid is
ecosystric
and the genome is a single stranded
positive rna 7.2 kilobase
with three open reading frame or rf1 or
f2
and or f3
there is a fourth orf
that is
overlapping of one for certain strain
belonging to one specific genotype
genotype one
this virus belongs to the epiveryday
family
and this family contains two genus or to
epiverus and pc epiverus
the generous ortho epi varies contain
four species autoipi various a b
c and d
and the strains that can be transmitted
to to human belongs mainly to
autoipivorous a species
containing eight genotypes
and only one serotype but also
two auto epiverse c
and
the main genotypes are genotype one two
four
these genotypes are a
located
in different parts of the world as you
can see here genotype 1 and 2
are found in
low-income countries
and they are strictly found in in human
and these genotypes are transmitted
via contaminated water
and genotypes three and four
are found outside this uh area uh in
many parts of the world
mainly asia for genotype four and in the
other parts of the world for genotype
three
genotypes three and four are zoonotic
and this is important there is a large
animal reservoir mainly constituted by
pigs a wild board
and and also deer and and rabbit
uh
this uh
publication ranked the risk of animal to
human spillover
and you can see here that hepatitis e uh
virus is
uh
among the
10
top 10
pathogens
as you can see just after
cyril varus and nipah virus
an important characteristic of this
virus is a quasi-envelope virus these
virus uh circulate in the blood with a
lipid envelope
and uh
when the the virus reach the the bile
uh the envelope is destroyed by uh
the
pancreatic
[Music]
enzymes
uh and also by the uh deoxycolic acid
so the virus that is found in the
intestinal tract is a naked virus this
envelope play an important role for cell
entry
a tissue or tropies finance activity but
also these envelopes allow the virus to
escape to neutralizing antibodies
the hiv life cycle is
shown here
beside the virus that is produced at the
uh apical and at the baselateral side of
the hepatocytes
the capsid protein can be secreted as a
free form
uh
uh in in in the in the blood
and also in the in the bile
uh we recently demonstrated that this
virus can replicate in the intestinal
tract
by using
primary intestinal cells
and also human intestinal tissues
and so
we propose a new concept that the virus
replicates in the intestine
and then reach
the bile as an enveloped
form
and this envelope virus infect the
hepatocytes
there are in fact two epidemiological
and clinical entities
genotype one and two that are strictly
found in human uh in fact
young adults
and they
can induce feminine hepatitis in
pregnant women and in patients with
pre-existing liver disease
but these genotypes cannot
induce chronic infection
genotype 3 to 8 and mainly genotype 3
and 4
induce acute hepatitis in adults older
than 55
they induce fulminant hepatitis but only
in patients with pre-existing liver
disease
and these genotypes can induce chronic
infection in immunocompromised patients
it is important to undermine that all
these genotypes give asymptotic and very
frequent asymptomatic infections
a particular
point
interesting point is a
pathogenicity of hepatitis e virus
during the pregnancy
and uh our recent studies showed that in
fact
this pathogenicity is genotype dependent
genotype one
end use uh
on the
using tacental tissue we show that
genotype one induce a high level of
replication
tissue necrosis and apoptosis and a very
specific uh profile of cytokine
that is very different of what is found
for uh hiv genotype three
with hiv genotype iii the level of
replication is very low
and there is no tissue necrosis and
no apoptosis and and the cytokine
profile is completely different uh
compared to
hdv genotype one and this is plain that
genotype wine and and probably two are
very pathogen
during the pregnancy
there are also neurologic manifestation
for this virus
uh according to case report and case
series uh so retrospectively the
frequency was first estimated to be 5.5
percent
and the main uh neurologic syndrome are
passionate turner guillain-barre and
encephalitis
and
in a french prospective study performed
by florence
several years ago
in fact the pre the frequency was higher
16.5 percent
uh and we found uh
also the same pathology but also
neuropathic plain pain painless
sensatory disorders
and it was interesting to to show that
this neurologic manifestation were more
frequent in immunocompetent patients uh
compared to immunocompromised patients
and this
means that probably
immunologic mechanisms are involved
in the pathogenicity of the of the virus
nevertheless it is possible to detect
the virus in the csf
and uh
in a recent study a performer florence
we we showed that
in fact uh
we can see a compartmentation uh of the
virus
in patients who had neurologic
manifestation and a chronic infection
and in fact uh
we can see here that the virus found in
the csf in in green
the plants
found in the center are very different
to the clone found in the blood and this
is similar for this patient
an important point is the
treatment of hepatitis e
and the treatment concern mainly chronic
hepatitis e
and uh
several years ago in 2010 we demonstrate
for the first time an antiviral effect
of the of ribavirin
as you shown the ribavirin was a main
treatment with interferon for hepatitis
c
and so uh it's a reason why we try we
did this study and we showed that
fibavirine in monotherapy
can
give an eradication in this series there
were eight patients and six out of eight
patients were cured after three months
of treatment
in fact we uh
demonstrate we confirm this uh
efficacy of ribavirin in a french
multi-centric
study that included 59 patients and the
rate of hev eradication after three
months of rebarbarian immunotherapy was
78
and more recently
in a large europe reopened
retrospective multi-center study
with a 250
patients
we observe the same rate of
eradication
with
81.2
percent
and
in fact some of the patients who were
not cured up
after the first line of rebarbarian
therapy were killed after a second
course
uh so the
the the
the rebarini is very effective
so i can
now
[Music]
give florence for the
for the next part of the talk
okay thank you jack
so i will
focus my my talk on the diagnosis of
hepatitis e virus infection
first i will remind you all the markers
that can be detected during the natural
course of an hiv infection
as you can see
the incubation period is around two to
six weeks in general it's one month
and when it is symptomatic we have a
journey at the same time as we have the
elevation of alt the liver enzymes
but
hiv rna or hiv antigen as
jack has just told you we can detect
also the antigen the capsid antigen that
is
secreted as a soluble form in the blood
so all these markers can be detected in
the blood or in the stool of an infected
patient it can be detected before the
the symptomatic phase but also for a few
period after the symptomatic phase but
this
different var marker doesn't last for
long
and that's why the surgical markers are
very important
usually igm are positive at the acute
physiology infection and soon after we
can detect igg
so this is a natural course for
immunocompetent patients that usually
clears the infection
but as jack told you we have chronic
hepatitis e virus infection with
genotype 3 and genotype 4 and in that
case
the
all the markers persist hiv arena in the
blood in the stool and
hiv and gene
but also we have noticed that igm are
still positive during the chronic course
of the infection in this patient
recently the european association for
the study of the liver
have
proposed an algorithm for the diagnosis
of ngiv
infection
and they really ensure that every
patient with an elevation of liver
transaminase should be test for hiv
infection even if he has not traveled
abroad
for european people
in immunocompetent patient the diagnosis
rely on igm and sometimes ngg and a
confirmation can be made with hev arena
ac
of course he is positive you can
conclude that you have an acute
hepatitis e and you can screen for
extra hepatitis manifestation especially
in logical muscle infestation
any risk of
acute and chronic liver failure and so
on
in immunocompromised patients it's very
important to
perform both the serology and hdv rna
because this theory can be negative as
the acute phases of the infection
of course this patient
may present the risk of evolution to a
chronic infection so we have to test for
them for hiv rna after three months to
see say there is a viral clearance or
the persistence of the virus
so in our experiments i would say that
anti-hiv igg
essays are used to see the exposure or
previous or current exposure to the
virus
anti-hev igm aces are very a key marker
or a key tool for the diagnosis of an
acute or recent infection
whereas
hev rnase are here to confirm the acute
infection
to assess immunocompromised patients the
persistence or the clearance of
immunocompromised human compromised
patients and of course it will be
necessary to test for hiv rna for the
treatment follow-up when
they are given
re-bothering
alternative to pcr essay to detect hiv
rna is a possibility to detect
the antigens the rf2 protein in the
blood
it's not used so much in france but it
has some interest
i would like to take take your attention
on the long persistence of igm
in this spanish study
they show that the rate of detection
may depend on the sensitivity of the ac
that you use especially the anti-hev igm
ac
maybe i use as you can see
using the microgen sc
you can detect igm
in nearly 40 percent of the cases
three years after the acute phase
it's less important with a one-time igm
essay but it's sometimes very difficult
so to re-assess
the importance of the asus igm
positive igm
since the acute phases many years or
many months ago
so several anti-agm
ec are now available especially
we have a rapid test or
well what we call now with uh echo the
correct pandemic the lateral flow essay
they are very rapid and very useful in a
resource limited countries for instance
they are easy to use with a visual
result get in a very few minutes
but their sensitivity
will vary according to the essay
it is around ninety percent for amino
competitive patients and six seventy
percent for immunocompromised patient
note that they have a very excellent
specificity with a very few false
positive results
microplate acer are also available with
several providers that are on the market
now
and have many studies have investigate
their sensitivity and specificity
all of them have a very good specificity
and their specific sensitivity and
immunocompetent patient range from 60 to
88 percent so it's quite good
of course it's less important in
immunocompromised patients even if we
have few
studies that have already investigate
this marker in immunocompromised patient
we have also a few automatic systems the
one by
biomarkers on the vdas instrument we
have evaluated this system a few years
ago it was also an excellent specificity
with a good sensitivity in
immunocompetent patient and less
sensitive for immunocompromised patients
but
there are only few studies for the
allegria automat
this automatis was investigated in a few
studies with small number of patients
and these patients were not very well
characterized i'm not sure that they
were all immunocomplicated patients
but their sensitivity
is around 90 to
100
also although they also found an
excellent specificity and i will go
further and talk later of the new
instrument that is available with
jesserine
regarding anti-hev itg sa we don't have
any immunochromatographic essay
available for that
but we have several macroplate or
automatic instruments that have
developers a kind of essay
but the main problem of all these ac is
that
present a large difference in
sensitivity
by using the double va chose standard
we can estimate the limit of detection
of all gsa and several studies has done
this studies
and as you can see
the limit of detection of all the
different essays varies from 2.6 to 0.2
wa-2 international unit per ml
this large difference in sensitivity has
a great impact as it has been shown in
this meta-analysis of anti-hiv
therapeutics in france in europe sorry
as you can see
using different sa will give you very
different sr prevalence
this estimate of the serous problems in
europe range from two percent with the
advertising to a 17 percent with a
one-time essay
and of course
it will depend also of the geographic
origin of the patient and the court
study the one-time essay is now
considered as a more sensitive essay
with a limit of detection of 0.2 degree
2 units per ml
so i will
then go
further with the antigenesis there's
only one available now in europe
it has also very good specificity 100
and
it is uh it was investigating several
studies and
the sensitivity varies according to the
study between
60 and 90 percent for immunocomputed
patients
and 94 for immunocompromised patient
this essay is always less sensitive than
hev rna sa
but there's a good correlation between
the positivity of this antigen sc and
the pcr asa
but
antigen sc are usually positive for
corresponding heve rna concentration of
about 2 3 to 4
logs copy per ml
interesting point is that this antenna
level uh could be a productive um
marker of the evolution of the infection
in immunocompromised patients
particularly in solid organ transplant
recipient
we have already shown
that
we in german study have shown that
patients that will evolve to a chronic
infection
have higher level of this antigen in
their blood
we have several molecular essays that
can detect hiv rna in the blood or in
the stools of the patient
there is also a
double vah-2h2 standard that can be used
to estimate the limit of detection of
this essay
you can see here all the providers that
are on the market in europe
we have two kinds of essays the
quantitative assays and the qualitative
essays the quantitative essay have a
limit of detection
ranging from 20 to
200
international units per ml
and we have also two essays that are on
two instruments apologic and rush
instrument
they have a lower limit of detection but
they are only qualitative they say and
are more dedicated to the screening of
blood donor
to test the screening of blood donor as
it is now recommended in several
countries in europe
a limit of all the molecular essays that
i have presented to you
is that they do not detect the auto
epivery see the species that is found in
rats
there are recent publication mainly
coming from hong kong that has shown
that this species can be found also in
human
we have also performed a pilot study in
more than 200 patients but we didn't
find any but we have to keep in mind
maybe that
this virus can also be found in humans
so let me now present to you the
performance of the new mirex ltv igg and
igm essays that are available since few
months
on the diatherin instrument they can be
used on the lyzon excel or the lyson xs
instruments these are two fully
automatic chemisent immunoassays
that are
provided by diastolene for the diagnosis
of hepatitis e with or without symptoms
but also intend to screen for organ
tissue or
postmortem donors
the int itv itg essay is a quantitative
essay
it is a
result is given in intelligent national
units per ml whereas the anti-hev igmc
is only quite the tvc
and they can be used both on plasma and
serum samples
first we have assessed the specificity
of this essay by testing
more than 270 uh
patients
this patient where these samples were
hiv negative for rna and for antibodies
by using altona esa in pcr and wanted sc
for the theology
they came from neocomputant and
immunocompromised patient
and as you can see the specificity of
the anti-igg was very elevated with more
than 99 of the
samples that were negative
so it's a very excellent specificity but
it's even better for the anti-agm
specificity as no sample tested positive
with the liaison anti-hm
hev agm sc
to assess the sensitivity of the ac we
have test
88 samples that were positive for hev
igm using the one die sa but also
positive for hiv rna this sample were
collected in immunocompetent and
immunocompromised patient
immunocompetent patients the sensitivity
of both sa are excellent igm and igg
were detected in all the patients and
interestingly it is an even better than
one time you see as
the anti-igg ac
was positive in only 91 percent of the
patient
in immunocompromised patient the
sensitivity of the igmsa was 93
0.7
and the sensitivity of the itgac was a
84 percent
at the same a little bit better than the
one-time igtse
we have also tested the
samples that were collected after their
acute hearts that mean that they were
igm positive using the one-time test
but they were hiv-rna-negative
similarly they were
tested in immunocompetent and
immunocompromised patient
and in the tooth population
we can see that the sensitivity of the
igm essay is a little bit less
important for igm but it's similar to
the one-time ac for the detection of igg
and
it's more than 90 percent for igg and
you have the the numbers uh 70 um sorry
57 percent for igm
patient and 71
immunocompromised patient
finally wanted also to
test patients from
infected with non-urban gentiles and in
non-genotype three genotypes as we have
usually in france or in europe
that's why we have tests
four samples coming from patients
infected with hiv genotype one
two samples coming from patients
infected with genotype two
and as you can see
all this sample tested positively with
the liaison and the oneplus sa for igg
and igm
regarding genotype 4
infection we tested the 5 patients
4 out of 4 tested positive for both igg
and igm with leso and wanted essays
and
maybe interestingly one patient was only
positive for itg and negative rgm using
liaison or anti-isis
this profile may suggest a re-infection
in this patient
so to sum up this evaluation of the
performance of the numerix essay
we can conclude that this is
an excellent specificity for both idg
and igmsa
we also found an excellent sensitivity
in accused face in birth
particularly in immunocompetent patients
the level of sensitivity also for ige is
very remarkable
that means that this essay has a very
low level
of lower limit of detection
according to the package insert it is
0.3
unit per ml so it's similar to
anti-ac
so this essay will be suitable for
epidemiological study
newspaper may have a lower limit of
detection for long-lasting egm igm
after an acute phase but to my knowledge
it's not very necessary to have this
high sensitivity several months after an
accurate infection
and even if you are test a limited
number of different genotype i really
feel confident that i'm seeing these
essays as the ability to detect
antibodies against the different hiv
genotypes
so thank you for your intention
thank you jacques and florence for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
for jacques
is there a vaccine for hepatitis e
as the answer is yes
there is a vaccine for h hepatitis e
this vaccine was developed in in china
several years ago and a
large clinical trial
proved
the efficacy of this vaccine and the
name is e.colin
unfortunately for now this vaccine is
restricted to to china the
there are clinical
trials
in progress but
outside
china this vaccine is not
available yet
thank you our next question is for
florence
which is the relevance of automatic
systems for serology
well the main relevance for automatic
system is a rapid
detection of igm and the rapid
system to perform a diagnosis of acute
hepatitis especially because we are
working in a hospital it's very
important to give a rapid answer to the
clinician if it is an hepatitis e or
another source of
acute biotitis for the patient
so this is very important not to perform
because we were used to use a microplate
essays not to perform
batch analysis but a random access
analysis so the main relevance is the
rapidity and of course
the random access of
this automatic system
thank you
our next question is for jacques
which kind of treatment in addition to
ribovarin are available for hev
management
in fact unfortunately uh
the the choice
uh of drug uh outside ribborine is very
limited there is in fact only interferon
alpha interferon
that can be used in liver transplant
patients in case of failure
as i mentioned the rate of
failure is approximately
10 to 20 percent
after treatment with the ribbering and
for liver transplant patient and
efferent can induce a cure
but
in fact alpha interferon cannot be used
in for other transplant patients due to
the risk of rejection
uh and this reason why uh there are
many labs work to find uh alternative
therapy for in case of failure of uh
re-bavirin
thank you
it looks like we have time for one more
question this question is for florence
which is the
impo which is the importance of igm
detection
in acute and post-acute phases
so for acute physics this is a
main marker that is
relevant for the diagnosis even in
france we
recommend only to use igm ac
to detect an acute hepatitis in
immunocompetent patient
hiv arena is not necessary in this
population to diagnose a hiv infection
so this is really the key marker for the
diagnosis immunocompetent patient like
it is for hav
infection hepatitis a and infection
it's more difficult maybe to detect and
more
relevant to detect igm at the post-acute
phase when the liver enzyme are back to
the normal
sometimes it was useful
i remember a study we performed when we
have studied many patients have
participated to winning a meal
and there were tests three months after
the wheeling meal to see if it was a
cluster of acute hepatitis linked to
this
meal
but
of course it's more epidemiology studies
in that case than a real
diagnosis of acute hepatitis
so it's very important to have a very
specific and sensitive essay at the
acute phase i feel it's less important
to have a sensitive essay for the
post-theoremic phase when alt are going
back to the normal
okay thank you again jacques and
florence for your time today and your
important research
we would also like to thank rat lab
roots and our sponsor diosorin for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye